[Music]
the sheep in this world and their wolves
in this world
and I've known that YouTube are they're
just too weird travelers who lost their
way so we don't clean you up right with
a baptism I'm more on baptism by fire
time okay come to my wrestling school
and become a badass that's what he wants
to do with the rest of his life
yes it is hmm you got a half-naked boy
with Down syndrome who has no idea how
to get along in this room just slip out
from under your nose oh you two are
close we are well then you'll figure out
where he's at you'll bring him back are
you following me maybe we could be
friends and buddies bro dogs and chill
have a good time scene in wrestling
schools maybe yeah one long road leads
all the way down I'll drop you there I'm
looking for a missing person have you
seen him little man Elena let's go from
back there Eleanor
too bad it's on the road oh yeah
number one don't slow me down rule
number two I'm in charge
hey what's me number one party
no not party you have a young boy with
Down's syndrome in the middle of nowhere
all right well while you've been doing
paperwork we've been doing something
called living ahead tell her I'm gonna
give you all I'm my horses for my
birthday I made a promise to him
give me that wrestling school Aidan no
we're not gonna hop on your little raft
and cruise around down the ribs so how
far is it not that far enough are your
fingers to scale yeah
[Music]
I think it's time for us to go back now
we could be a family friends are the
family in tune
wrestlers got alter egos you need a name
Falcon peanut butter burger
[Music]